oh
yes awesome
oh man oh no groggy
winked at him are you a jedi
what do you think don't go to the weird
creepy uncanny valley jedi
[Laughter]
of course he's there oh man why
oh my god welcome back to new rockstars
this is our reaction to the mandalorian
season 2 episode 8 chapter 16
the season finale the rescue about
another spoiler warning before we
continue
but the rescue of this episode comes at
the hands or i should say hand
plus robot hand of a jedi who just got
his own rogue one kill box sequence luke
skywalker
deep fake edition look at a bit more
battlefront 2
than return to the jedi but hey hey this
is disney plus they'll be in there with
a vfx render patch by new year's
this is wookielakes it's our mandalorian
after show i'm eric voss here with tommy
bechtold hey buddy
hello wow yes that was i you know i'll
take luke skywalker
anyway they can do them like a rank and
bass christmas special claymation and
i'm still in
yeah and hey they they gave him some of
the best luke lightsaber action
we have ever seen they did not have his
face in those shots but
we didn't need it he was on a security
camera and it looked terrifying for the
dark troopers
yes as we deduced after chapter 14
groku's first link on that tithe on
scene stone was
with a post return of the jedi luke
skywalker there is
a lot to unpack with the star wars
timeline and what this means for grogu's
future
is he gone from the show permanently is
he coming back
we'll talk about that but first just a
quick reminder to get your limited
edition this
is the way shirt exclusive from new
rockstars official merch
store newrockstarsmerch.com we've been a
bit surprised by how much demand there
has been from the general public finding
us on
like google people who have no idea what
an eric vos even
is and we felt kind of bad that the last
of the collectible shirts might go to
people who don't even care about this
channel or collecting them
and then the and our chosen ones like
you
might not be able to get one so here's
what we did we are dropping a coupon
in our diehards just for you guys to
make it so that the last of these shirts
can go to the true fans who we believe
deserve them
now we might still have a few more red
and white varieties by the time you're
watching it
so jump on this fast because once the
last of them are gone
back in the vault they go that's what
makes them special is they do not live
forever
uh there is also a bunch of new designs
in case you miss it
there uh there's an easter egg line
that's filled with a bunch of cool
hidden references that you can find
so people can just like stare at your
chest forever and then
we just released an amazing new grogu
shirt that looks great
uh so again go to newrockstarsmerch.com
that url or epic heroshop.com
those two are the only official urls for
our store
do not get suckered by all the scammers
out there there are some uh
clone sites that have popped up don't
get screwed by them make sure you go to
one of our official sites
but um thanks to the people who did buy
this shirt in the past week their shout
outs are gonna appear below we got
dart vega who says master vos master
bechtold i wish to further trade in the
ways of the nerd at the new rock stars
temple
yeah there's not much to train it's
just spending too much time watching
things and then oh
our editor john got some love from
nicole
john you will always be my way
johnny boy a-e-t-s jets jets
jets job all right uh tommy there's so
much that happened this episode break
down this episode for us what happened
all right well we get a saucy saucy
little diner scene with bo katan and
fellow mandalorian koskarevs
as they agree to help rescue grogu after
uh like a
kind of a weirdly petty fight between
reeves and boba fett where uh obviously
the mandalorians take umbrage with but
with boba wearing that armor
and they insult him the old the most
deeply insulting way we know how by
calling him a clone
stupid clone in exchange for her help
boca tan wants uh the dark saber from
gideon and then also wants mando to
consider helping
her uh liberate mandalore the group
kidnaps dr pershing and then they take
his shuttle
uh and they and they crash landed and
gideon's cruiser what a cool
moment where they pretended they needed
to make an emergency landing with boba
fett expertly
uh shooting like a storm trooper just
close enough to make it look threatening
uh before he blasts yeah yeah and they
they cleverly block the launch tube as
well right
yeah they they force it so that no other
uh tie fighters can get out of there
absolutely so then bokeh tan koska
fennek and dude
do a uh avengers uh girls get it done
moment where they just go through and
mow down all of the
stormtroopers on the cruiser's bridge
meanwhile mando
finds the dark troopers just a second
too late as one has gone through he gets
a big
terminator energy there when he's just
punching him through the wall
that was awesome uh but he finally uses
that best car
spear to finish off uh one of the dark
troopers
uh and then he ejects the rest uh
through a vacuum
into space and at that point he is able
to go and liberate grogu from moth
gideon
uh and then to put mafition under and
defeat him with the best guard spear
and unfortunately claiming the dark
saber in the process so that makes him
the new rightful owner of the dark saber
he defeats him in combat
so all these technicalities it's like
playing a really confusing board game
uh when is it my turn how many rounds
are in each turn
why do i have the dark saber now uh
unfortunately the guard
you know what the rule is tommy it's
like the it's like the tim allen santa
claus rule where he accidentally causes
santa claus's death and then he himself
has to become santa claus
that's santa
yeah this is the dark saber clause uh
saber claws
sounds great okay so dark troopers
return and things
are looking pretty bad when all of a
sudden an x-wing flies by
and that can only mean one thing a jedi
has arrived
grogu reached out into the voids of
space
uh so so that jedi uh ends up being
luke skywalker and as we have already
discussed an incredible sequence of just
destroying
the dark troopers uh very very
satisfying for any fans of lightsaber
battles
so uh that leads to uh
with the most heartbreaking moment of
this show by far
the mandalorian and grogu are separated
mandalorian gives girl group permission
to go train with skywalker because as
luke skywalker says
uh talent is nothing without proper
training
so so mandalorian realizes he's got to
get his son into the best
uh best private schools if he's going to
make the nba for jedis so
i get it i understand i i'm sure i'll
have a similar issue with my son who
will make
a professional sports league or he just
won't come home
uh so anyway i then stopped watching
and uh just sat on the couch and kind of
heavily sighed before i was informed
that there was a scene at the end
so i had to go back and re-watch and
that scene is uh
fat emphatic traveling to jabba's palace
on tatooine
where boba fett kills bib fortuna who
has not missed a meal
since the uh battle i i like that like
if you take
job as throne you just become job alike
like it's like uh
christopher watkins theory that however
like however big your hair is you're
you'll gain weight to fill out your big
hair that christopher walken
used to say that if he grew his hair too
long he got fatter because
he would make his face make sense with
the hair yeah no that throne
is so comfortable you never want to get
up there's just like a toilet seat there
and there's like these uh snacks chips
that come up from the armrest
and it's got everything you need it's
the best gamer chair in the world
and boy are you right that there is most
definitely a toilet seat and that toilet
seat leads to where the rancor used to
live
uh which is just disturbing so so
fat kills bib fortuna and claims jabba's
throne
and we are then given the uh
announcement that the book of boba fett
is coming in december 2021
yeah and that's it that's it that's all
that's the only thing
that's all that happened in that episode
that's all that that's it that's it
bit of a filler episode no man
more star wars shows like i thought we
were filled up on star wars shows and it
really was like more
more yeah it was uh wild to get that
yeah uh but tommy seeing luke and we
knew it was luke from the moment the x
fighter landed and definitely from the
moment that green lightsaber ignited
uh it wasn't just like uh easy you know
haha you're dead you're dead you're dead
he was working
to kill all those stormtroopers he had
to force pull him he was forced pushing
him he was crushing him it really did
feel like darth vader's kill box and
broke one
uh it's like father like son and it was
beautiful
the way the symmetry rhymed yes agreed
i uh it was it was awesome and um
and i'll say that i think they needed
that
because they knew that with the tv show
budget even with disney plus money
there's only so much you can do to claw
your way out of that uncanny valley when
you're trying to deep
fake someone to be younger and he looked
pretty good
until as always he started talking and
that it's just so hard to
match the motion of the lips and the
teeth just because there are
so many little wrinkles down by our
mouth
by our lips the way they connect to our
gums and our teeth when our mouth
opens it's so hard for animators to try
to vividly do that
um but i mean i don't know tommy i've
seen control-alt-face videos that
looked a bit better than what we saw in
this episode
yeah yeah it was uh it was a little
rough it was so
confusing that i had a tough time
discerning what i was really looking at
like i i was like is this a is this like
a person with prosthetics on their face
like what it like it looked it looked
like it was really
hard for luke skywalker to talk which is
which to to your point and and i think
for me
at this point i think it's just a
natural
thing that i'm sure a lot of other
people do i just go into like a soft
focus so i'm barely even
concentrating on what his face looks
like that's really the only way i can
like you know not uh not not not obsess
over the
like the mouth not looking right is i
just kind of stop looking
concentrating on the face and just kind
of try and look at the whole screen
which i realize is weird
and yeah again i'm just happy luke
skywalker is there but it was
not not the best and i think that's
that's how we all feel about this the
way the way they did this is a lot of
people are thinking they're going to
bring in sebastian stan no no they get
like
a stand-in actor who just looks a lot
like matches a facial structure in this
case it was max lloyd jones
um but um in the past they've done this
with carrie fisher where they just got
an actress who kind of matches her
facial structure uh
and they've done this in the marvel
movies with uh with lawrence fishburne
and one of the ant-man movies with
uh with kurt russell and guardians of
galaxy vol 2. they actually got the kid
from the mighty ducks uh
to do that um yeah so yeah there's uh
there's a whole
story this it's always a little awkward
i don't know if they'll ever get it
right just because i think human beings
know what faces look like and we're
always gonna know
when it's not animated right we're
always gonna know when it's animated
versus when it's not animated but
the real question here is what's gonna
happen with grogu now that he's in the
hands of luke skywalker
is he not on the show anymore will he
come back
and where is luke in history at this
point
that's gonna be our big question we're
gonna dive into this first
just because we know that's what you
guys have all been asking us so
uh go with me on this tommy a week
before last i i explained how
until now we've been in kind of this
mystery period with luke skywalker's
timeline
like the mandalorian has set in nine aby
return of the jedi was five years before
and four aby
between four and five aby uh that was
when luke trained leia we saw that in
the flashback of the rise of skywalker
but that training
ended in five baby y when leia gave
birth to ben
solo so yes right now ben solo future
kylo ren is alive
in the mandalorian he is about four
years old um
luke after that was kind of in the
middle of a search for knowledge about
the history of the jedi in the sith
uh and both sides of the force he got
this kind of balanced view of that whole
history
and we did see part of that search in
the battlefront 2 game where
luke finds the emperor's old vault he
gets his holocron that
has a star map to och 2. actually
i think luke might have been scouting on
otch 2
when grogu pinged him from the tython
scene stone
i think that might he just might have
happened to be there meditating
um however luke will not begin creating
his
new jedi order that we see in the sequel
trilogy for like another six years
that's around 15 aby ben solo was around
10 years old when that started
so that's a that's a bit away from now
there's still more of this mystery
period
in which we can explore luke's
relationship with grogu
like roku might meet max von said house
character laura santeka who was an
important
uh confidante and friend to luke
skywalker during that period
uh grogu could actually be a member
of the early ranks of luke's jedi order
2.0
in fact tommy i'm wondering if maybe it
was luke's favoritism toward grogu
that could have planted the seeds of
resentment and ben solo
maybe ben as some people are saying it's
possible that ben
when right before he turned into kylo
ren killed grosgu when he burned that
jedi temple
in fact maybe it's grogu's grave on
notch too
that's what luke was looking at when rey
found him at the end of the force
awakens but it is worthy to consider
that stuff
i'm not so sure that's how grogu's story
is gonna
end because think about it over the next
couple decades grogu is about to age
rapidly grogu is 50 years old yoda was a
jedi master by age 100.
that's only like 50 years away from
gurogu he's got to go through a lot he's
got to hit
puberty he's got his teenage years his
young adult years his middle age years
all that's about to happen
so under luke skywalker's tutelage grogu
is gonna grow goo into a badass
um but i do have a feeling that training
will end
once luke takes on ben solo as an
apprentice um
just because grogu was not at all in the
picture in the sequel trilogy
or the flashbacks or the prelude comics
that showed young ben
luke's depression that uh rey found him
to have on ach 2 might have been the
result of two failed apprentices
who left him grogu and ben so grogu's
destiny is still his own
um and i think it is not a permanent
partnership with luke for sure
in fact i don't think we will see this
version of a live
action luke skywalker again on the
series this feels like a one-time event
for me
um but the next time we see grogotomy
could be on the other side of that
training we might see a time jump
uh when we come back in season three and
in the way that episode two
of the star wars uh saga uh between two
and three we had that big time jump on
the
end of the clone wars and then uh the
whole character of
uh anakin skywalker went from kind of a
a teen
to um someone who's just on the cusp of
being a wiser jedi master
i think we might see that maturation
process with grogu
and i think that's why they named him
here rather than calling them the child
or baby yoda
i think people want him to be identified
as grogu so that when we see him come
back we don't say like what is this
teenage baby oda now it'll just be like
oh no it's just grogue he's just older
yeah i i uh that's gonna be
that's gonna be a disney marketing uh
research uh masterpiece is how they
figure out how
what uh a speaking grogu sounds like
and how to not piss people off because
it's very they made him a cooing kind of
cute
baby crossed with like almost like a
purring kitten
you know what i mean like the the the
the sounds baby yoda makes the bear
groggy makes are
are very sweet and cute like a teenager
like a prepubescent
or like voice changing like what does
what does yoda sound like it's frank oz
like what is he gonna say
how do you even make his teenage voice
like what is is it like
is it like billy west or something like
that like i don't know like who does his
who does his best how are they going to
be he used to have
a friend named and i only got to see
his face once hey it's possible tommy we
never hear him talk he could be a
teenager who takes a vow of silence you
know like in
a little miss sunshine paul daniel's
character we didn't hear his voice
for the first time like that'd be kind
of fun with groga he's just like he is
so
moody he never says anything he's a
scouse
he's just he's just pissed because he
doesn't have the little
shifting cylinder anymore shifting the
shifter knob
that's his rosebud that's going to be
groga's rosebud that he the toy he had
to leave behind
um no but like i don't think this is the
last time we see grogu on the
mandalorian he
is so important to uh amanda's character
development
and yeah there's gonna be some
detachment i think this happens on a lot
of shows characters just don't see each
other
but then we have a time jump and there's
a reunion and that reunion feels really
really really good
um and i think we do need to see some
time for these two
apart just to see what the other forces
of their life
um the the jedi order uh and like the
mandalorian
code because you know denjarian still
has this other group of the watch who's
pretty dogmatic
versus the new mandalorians he's meeting
bogatan he's gonna have conflicts with
them
so we need to we need to develop those
people in those
parts those corners of the universe
before we bring them back together and
there's gonna be some later point in
their life where they're able to help
each other again and that's
that's such a meaningful thing i think
for everybody to be like we don't always
need
people in our lives for our entire life
sometimes friends come back to us
later in our lives once we've
experienced things separately
yeah for sure for sure uh yeah i agree i
don't think that this isn't the end of
ma
of grogu on mandalorian i just thought i
mean
that just doesn't make any sense i think
the the bigger reality
is that he won't be as big in season
three
but will still be a part of it and you
know maybe
maybe ultimately it's something that
like towards the end of season three
mando has to go get him or help him from
something and i think that
that could be not having luke skywalker
back is an easy fix he's just
off doing something right like he's off
on another planet solving a problem so
it's just like
you could even have a you know a five or
six year old cameoing as
ben solo just hanging out with grogu you
know
or like you know chewbacca's like
babysitting him or something but i think
ultimately
they'll bring them back together like
you said well there are more questions
we have to dig into specifically with
the dark saber why is it such a point of
contention uh but first we want to thank
some friends who helped us make this
episode starting with expressvpn
it's december and if you're like me
you're probably just watching
christmas movies this whole month that's
all we really can do
what if you were to go to netflix and
discover that your favorite christmas
movie just
isn't available on that platform well
get ready to have your mind blown folks
because
you can use expressvpn to watch any
netflix library in the world
this weekend you could use expressvpn to
stream love actually on the german
netflix or
die hard on south korean netflix it is
simple it's
you just open the app you hit one button
to change your location refresh netflix
and yipikaye
dank ferrix express vpn lets you control
where you want sites to think you're
located you just choose
from almost 100 countries that's a lot
of netflix libraries to explore
expressvpn works with any streaming
service netflix disney plus hulu you
name it there are hundreds of vpns out
there but i use expressvpn to watch
movies and shows because it is
ridiculously fast there's never any
buffering and you can always stream in
hd
expressvpn works with all your devices
your phones tablets smart tvs
so you can use it to watch whatever you
want on the go or the big screen
and if you visit my special link right
now expressvpn.com
mandalorian you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free
support this show watch what you want
and get your holiday fix at
expressvpn.com mandalorian we also want
to thank our friends from manscaped so a
long time ago in a galaxy far far away
men actually shaved their balls with the
same razor as their face
not anymore thanks to our sponsors at
manscaped the best in men's below the
way screaming
manscaped is here to help you look
smooth like lando
level smooth whether you're going to be
applying multiple layers of prosthetics
to really nail your mon calamari cosplay
or you just or you want that nice fresh
deep fake looking luke skywalker face
without getting scarred and you want it
on your balls um
manscape is forever changing the
grooming game with their perfect package
3.0
inside the perfect package you'll find
their electric trimmer the lawnmower 3.0
it's waterproof and skin safe it will
reduce those nicks
and help you achieve that look that even
admiral ackbar would admire
and this is not a trap it also includes
the crop preserver anti-chafing ball
deodorant and moisturizer the crop
reviver ball toner spray
and the anti-chafing performance boxer
briefs in a very sharp
black color that is downright imperial
get
20 off and free shipping at manscape.com
mandalorian that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
mandalorian may the force be with your
balls all right
also with yours i got some questions for
you now
first question will the dark saber
become a wedge between
mando and bogatan why is claiming by
combat such a big deal to poketan now
when it wasn't when sabine gave her the
dark saber
yeah that's a really good question um
because you're
reminding us of the moment bogatan
received the dark saber
sabine wren just found it on rebels and
then handed it to her and pogade did not
say like
okay i have to kill you though if i want
to take that no
that wasn't the rule then um but it was
kind of
this is the stark saber is a pride of
the mandalorians uh house of visa had it
and they were the warrior family
and maul took it from uh from the head
of house visa
um but maul lost it he wasn't like uh
he wasn't dethroned it wasn't like the
elder wand he wasn't
defeated in a duel for sabine ran to get
that saber
here's what i think it tells us i think
that rule
came into effect when moth gideon beat
uh boca tan i think that was such a
humiliation
for boca tan and the only way
that like she was able to justify the
principle
of moff gideon now wielding it is the
fact that
he just beat her fair and square in a
duel
uh and so he can rightfully wield it now
and it's now such a point of contention
in her heart that she
has to go back and try to reclaim this
desolate destroyed world of mandalore it
feels like a don quixote type mission
why does she care that much and i think
it's just because her pride has been
stung and she needs this
uh comeback tale uh and and maf gideon
knows that i think he was smart
by when he realized that mando was like
i don't need the dark saber i just want
the kid
mop kitty's like ooh but i know bo katan
wants his saber
so i'm gonna force him to fight me and
even if he beats me either i beat him
which is obviously great or he beats me
and then it creates this wedge issue
with between him and
bo kate um so i think uh
she needs it back because she lost it it
may not have always been the rule
and maybe even when she got it from
sabine ranch she's like you know what
but i didn't truly earn it
and i think in her head she knows that
because she didn't really earn it moff
getting was able to snatch it from her
and she was not worthy then
she needs to be worthy now to have it
but speaking of gideon tommy i want to
know from you what do you think is next
for him he was knocked out
he wanted to kill himself out of fear of
luke skywalker which is awesome
but he's still alive so what further
damage could he do do you think
uh you know for me i think well let's
see what so we've got a
uh a political extremist in moff gideon
uh who's now been taken prisoner i think
the only
move for him is to pivot to the world of
podcasting
uh and host a show called getting off my
chest which is uh just him
airing grievances out into the galaxy
trying to like create
unrest where he he's like a kind of a
sean hannity character
where he just kind of goes like wouldn't
it be great
if if uh if we just started accepting
the fact that stormtroopers
are helpful instead of always vilifying
them
uh no i i think what he'll do
what's gonna happen is what always
happens in star wars which is
whatever the current scheme is is always
just one layer of a larger deeper darker
scheme
he's obviously got allies that are evil
nefarious
helpers that once he is captured are
going to seek to liberate him
and move on to the next phase of the
diabolical scheme like that's just the
nature of star wars
there is a force for good that fights
for freedom and justice and all of the
right things
and there's a force for bad that is a
never-ending supply of bad ideas
so we'll see whatever the next bad idea
for muff gideon is gonna be
i imagine another another uh evil entity
will emerge that has been
you know in league with moff gideon all
along and and and then
like i said i think he'll just another
evil scheme will come about and and
uh and he'll be somehow rescued
uh by bad guys is my guess what do you
think yeah i
i agree with you tommy i think there one
thing that we learned from this season
is that alderaan keeps coming back up
and for the first time we really got to
get a sense of the ideology of people
who serve the empire
they're still wrong i don't think the
show's drawing a false equivalence
between um
between space nazis and terroristic
freedom fighters
but it is saying that like the people
who serve the empire aren't just taking
a gig
like they really believe their mission
and i think that belief probably
trickles down to a lot of people across
the galaxy
maf gideon could be a murder figure now
by being imprisoned by this fledgling
new democracy who's barely keeping
control
who is imprisoning people if you look
through that prisoner registry by the
way of a couple episodes back
people are getting 50 years for like uh
falsifying credits for like money right
stuff like that
yeah obviously this new republic does
not know how to process prisoners very
well and i suspect that there
is a desperate need among the general
population of the galaxy
for prison reform and the new republic
is just making things worse
i mean the uh the empire just destroyed
planets
but the new republic in trying to be
more peaceful
is just having these overcrowded prison
populations and i think moff gideon is
going to manipulate that
and become a martyr and um create chaos
by the fact that he's in prison and the
fact that the new republic kind of sucks
absolutely all right another question
for you what will happen with grogu's
blood
and what's next for the genetic
engineering plot my
uh curiosity is what show this is going
to be followed up on is it going to be
on the mandalorian because if it just
follows the mandalorian like civil war
future civil war or reclaiming a
mandalore i don't see how the whole plot
line of uh
grogu's blood fits in with that it kind
of reminds me i think it's going to be
like in clone wars
where it jumps around to a lot of
different plots and they're all just
kind of
important in the galaxy um i don't think
we're going to get a separate
show with um with uh luke skywalker
and and goku i don't think it's going to
be there but
yeah i think if moff gideon is still a
part of this um
then yeah we're going to see the
continued efforts
of uh the whole strand cast plot and i
think next season is going to
go to where we thought this season was
going to go we're going to go to camino
next season we're going to uh
investigate further and it's just going
to be a mystery that the new republic is
desperately behind the curve on uh like
whoa
wait so your camino facility's still
active here wait there's a grogu
uh i'm just gonna go back to chandrila
and take some spice and let this all
blow over
spice you're so stupid um
gummies so tommy how do you think luke
knew
where to find the light cruiser if its
location was secret
uh how did luke just know like oh i'll
take the x-wing here my best
non-scientific answer would be that when
grogu reached out
into the you know the universe from that
ancient stone on titan
he created a bond with whatever jedi's
answered back maybe only luke maybe more
to be discovered
and i think once that bond was created
much like how uh
we kind of saw in the the new trilogy
that kylo
could track rey based on like if he got
deep enough into her mind
we don't know how deep into into a baby
into grotto whose mind luke skywalker
got
maybe he was able to see the
surroundings or see
what's happening and maybe he could kind
of listen in maybe these are like
maybe these are the seeds although we've
already seen them to full fruition in
the new trilogy
these are the seeds of the kind of the
new jedi mind tricks we were introduced
in the most recent trilogy
would be my guess oh so you're saying
that grogo at some point got to look out
a window and based off of the
arrangement of the stars
luke was able to wait a minute
triangulated
yeah or or once they figured out where
it was
cara dune sent out a beacon to you know
other like-minded republic uh officials
and they just told luke skywalker
maybe that just became an apb oh maybe
that's uh definitely a reasonable answer
i think grosgu just ate one of those
blue butterflies and each one of them
has a little gps tracker on it and
luke was like okay he ate a butterfly
this is good this is good
yeah for sure yeah i hope so i hope
that's what it is um all right
so next we're gonna move on to uh what i
thought the deeper meaning of this
episode was why this episode was so
important and how they did such a good
job underlining that deeper
meaning so obviously this whole season
was about unmasking mando both
physically and emotionally for his
character breaking away
him from that strict code of the watch
in which no one except pure mandalorians
can have vesgar
in which no one if you're a mandalorian
can show your face
episode by episode we saw that being
chipped away and some of that is thanks
to bo katan but really mostly it was
thanks to grogu the child
in chapter 15 he lets his face get
scanned in order to find gideon and
grogu
and here he does it again he finally
lets grogu see his full face after
giving him just a little peek when he's
sipping broth
earlier in the season uh there was a
final moment of connection
just to give that kid permission to go
it was it was like mando's way of saying
like just go
don't you know i don't want you anymore
oh god
okay yeah um
so i think this isn't just like uh an
ending to me this signals a new era for
denjarian
um grogu finally broke through that
shell and groga kind of took that shell
with him
and allowed amanda to show his true face
and i think he's going to continue to go
masculine
until he sees grogu again because think
about it how else will grogu recognize
him when they're like rebuilding the
mandalorian race
there's a ton of people with those
helmets on grogue's force sensitive he
might sense a connection
but i think there's going to be a thing
where like mando
keeps the light on and he's going to
keep the helmet off
so that groga can find him also pedro
pascal wants to show that pretty pretty
face
i was gonna say so like season three is
when he really gets to uh
be be on set a lot more not just in a
recording booth so
that's pretty cool because the show
needs a face the show
yeah groku has been the face of the show
while mano's helmet has been covering
his face i think pedro pascal
needs to now be the face of the show we
are going to close out with another
segment of mandos and man don'ts it's
our corrections corner
quickly going to recap the theories
predictions for past weeks we got oh so
right others we got
dead wrong i think we can claim victory
here tommy um
a lot of people really do this but our
first do was
luke was the jedi grog who linked with
on the python scene stone
and as i said he was not going to be
portrayed by sebastian stan but a man
don't i do believe i was skeptical that
they might try to de-age mark hamill
they totally did it totally looks a
little weird
it just looks it's just jarring right
like it's like
it's the fact that it's made that we're
just
have to accept it like these are human
actors on set with practical puppets and
people in costumes
then here is a very clearly animated
thing it's like
right this is clearly not real though
like you know i mean
real in the sense of like pedro pascal
is a real person who has
that face sasha banks is a real actress
who has that face
like that is not mark hamill that you
know like it's
it's his voice and it's his face
digitally
imposed onto someone else it's just
weird to just make that all work in your
mind
like you know more so than watching like
who framed roger rabbit where you're
like
okay obviously roger rabbit is a cartoon
rabbit but this is like no we're still
supposed to take him
and have the same emotions and feelings
towards this like rendered
thing anyway and if this character never
existed
you know it would be one thing with
grogu we know it's a puppet but
we feel it's real because this was
always how it looked on screen but the
fact that we had a reference point
with uh with mark hamill before what we
just saw in this episode what's never
luke skywalker or mark hamill this is
like a new thing and
that's what they call the uncanny valley
our brain just cannot
for the life of us associate the voice
we're hearing
as coming out of those lips uh and it's
always going to be a problem and they're
always going to
keep trying to get better at it maybe
one day they will and that will be a
very scary reality that we live in yeah
but i think it's a good thing that we
recognize this this is a little weird
um and uh and and i honestly tommy i
feel the same way about
when in the prequels they changed uh
yoda
to be they they made him a puppet a
frank oz puppet in the phantom menace
and then people thought that looked
weird so they made him a cgi character
in two and three and they went back to
phantom menace and put the cgi yoda over
him
and i always feel that disconnect with
yoda as that moment where he like
wipes his hair you know in in
stress it's like i i don't feel the same
way
if it's not practical yeah we did get a
little sidetracked here another man do
that i think we deserve some credit for
or i deserve some credit for
bitfortuna did show up this season
totally did not expect that i did kind
of predict that in a preseason
random promo breakdown and you know
after i said that i felt a little stupid
when the first season when the first
scene of this season was
uh that gore crashed planet that was
before tuna was nowhere to be found
but um i did look into bit portuna's
legends backstory i thought that was
wasted time it was not
he shows back up in the post-credits
scene which i love um
however i do have to uh also take credit
for uh
incorrect prediction grogu did not turn
evil
and he did not use the force to stab
gideon in the eye with that dark saber
i was really hoping we might get that
moment maybe it will come someday in the
future but not today
well that is it for this episode of
wikileaks but we're not done folks we
have one more episode it's gonna be a
very important season wrap up because we
have a lot of questions as we head into
the next season
uh keep your eyes out for that that's
gonna come out um next fridays and that
will be christmas day
so tommy and i will be spending
christmas together talking about that
that'll be fun my favorite follow me at
ea boss follow tommy at tommybeck told
subscribe to new rockstars on youtube
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcast
leave us a nice rating review i will be
back tomorrow with my easter egg
breakdown of this finale episode there's
a lot of cool little visual details they
put in there i can't wait to dig into
them
and we're going to leave you with uh the
most meaningful groku moment of the
episode
[Music]
you